[Music]
on this monday night
code red for humanity the un
sounds the alarm over irreversible
climate change
we are responsible for it the effects on
your health
and your livelihood canada relaxes
border measures for fully vaccinated
americans
the excitement where's the coldest beer
and the fears it's too
soon the political risk for the liberals
if they call
a federal election plus calls to boycott
the beijing olympics
i think it's very very cruel and unfair
to our ethnics the movement gaining
momentum
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
we begin with what the united nations is
calling a code red for humanity
a sweeping new report says the climate
is changing at an
unprecedented rate and without swift and
drastic cuts to greenhouse
gas emissions the world is on track for
catastrophe
the report from the international panel
on climate change involves the work of
234 scientists
and more than 14 000 studies they all
come to one unequivocal conclusion
humans are fueling climate change the
report also shows the world has warmed
by about 1.1 degrees celsius
since the late 19th century and it's
likely to surpass the 1.5 degree mark
in the next two decades the world is
already feeling the impact
from this summer's deadly heat wave in
british columbia to wildfires droughts
and devastating floods
worldwide those kinds of events are
projected to be even more severe
as the planet warms heather yorks west
has tonight's top story on what all of
this means for canada
and what experts say is needed to avoid
the worst case scenario
on the prairies the summer has been long
and hard
they say in this family farm my job is
to worry so i worry a lot
climate change is keeping ian mccreary
up at night
he's never seen drought conditions this
bad if we don't turn the corner on this
our children's opportunity to farm and
to live in parts of the world
that we currently live in will be much
more difficult
as we put more greenhouse gases and
especially carbon dioxide the major
greenhouse gas
into the atmosphere so we're increasing
its concentration
we're going to change the climate what
scientists have been warning for decades
is now happening before our eyes
a more than 3 thousand page report from
the united nations
intergovernmental panel on climate
change says the earth is getting warmer
and we
are already paying the price for canada
the report projects
reduction in 46 days with snowfall in
all but northern canada
a consistent signal toward an increase
in duration and intensity of droughts
a clear increase in the intensity and
frequency of hot extremes
and future increases in fire weather
basically the path
we're on now is one that threatens all
of the systems that sustain us so
whether that be
breathable air drinkable water
predictable climates all of that is at
risk
in bc a summer of heat and fire has
already cost
lives there was more than 500 people
that died due to the effects of
of heat some of my colleagues in the
interior of bc has certainly
seen a lot more uh uh
injuries due to due to smoke inhalation
increase in asthma and copd this is not
just a new normal
the science is clear that things will
get worse but how much worse depends on
what happens now and whether countries
like canada
can effectively lower the carbon
emissions linked directly with climate
change
i would say it's fair to say that that
none of us are
are doing enough right now and we've all
got to
take another look at what we are doing
and figure out how we can
improve and do more even he says if that
includes raising the price on carbon
on his farm the livelihood of the next
generation
is now at stake heather urex west global
news
calgary later we talked to one of the
lead canadian authors on the climate
report about the alarming findings and
what we can do to help turn things
around
but first the intense fire situation in
bc
the province is at the beginning of
another hot spell the wildfire danger is
ranked high to extreme
in two major areas of the province and
that could grow the most concerning fire
is burning in one of those two areas
ahmadagahi is there in kamloops with the
latest on the situation
ahmad well after cooler temperatures
over the weekend bc wildfire crews are
contending with another round of hot
and dry conditions starting today in the
province's southern interior where
perhaps this fire activity
is at its peak and threatening to get
worse with winds returning
this week as well there are about 270
wildfires
in bc burning right now two of the
largest
surround the kamloops area at this
moment the white rock lake fire between
kamloops and vernon
is burning through 55 000 hectares this
fire has caused
devastation in the community of monte
lake destroying
structures vehicles and scorching
properties it grew
exponentially last week doubling in size
in just 72
hours while it has forced evacuation
alerts and orders affecting thousands of
people
this while the nearby sparks lake fire
northwest of kamloops sits at
a mammoth 770 square kilometers and has
been burning since late
june there are more than 4 000 people
fighting bc wildfires at this juncture
of what is proved to be a difficult fire
season spurred by
drought-like conditions and extreme heat
bc's public
safety minister continues to assure the
province
is prepared they have resources they
have air support
they have all the equipment that they
need and they have been doing an amazing
job
now just in the last few days the bc
wildfire service has released its
august outlook and not surprising to
many it shows that the province isn't
out of the woods
yet the agency in charge of fighting
these fires is predicting
fires of note to grow with the potential
for
big spread events when the winds pick up
and the bc wildfire service is also
expecting another month of above normal
temperatures and below
normal levels of precipitation
ahmadigahi global news
it's not just bc severe wildfires are
raging around the world
across parts of north america and europe
hot and dry conditions are fueling some
of the worst fires in years
and scientists warn they offer a glimpse
of the future
jackson proskow reports
a summer of fire has whipped around the
world
flames are ripping through the
mediterranean torching vast swaths of
turkey and grease
and he doesn't know if this horror will
stop tonight
or tomorrow or in five days in italy the
work of an
arsonist quickly turned into a roaring
wildfire
humans may have lit the match but tinder
dry conditions
and high winds are the gasoline i call
it the perfect storm
we not only have the prolonged drought
that's been occurring
but we also have extreme temperatures
and then add to that high winds
and that carries the fire in california
the dixie fire is now the second largest
in state history
scorching nearly a quarter million
hectares and still only 20 percent
contained
entire towns have been wiped off the map
just devastation just killed me
no matter where the flames are burning
there are common themes
terms like extreme fire behavior have
become the norm
at times firefighters have been
completely surrounded and just like
residents forced to retreat even those
spared direct flames face an apocalyptic
landscape
scientists are unequivocal that
human-made climate change is to blame
the rise in temperatures and ensuing
drought will create
more extreme fire danger in the coming
decades
six times more extreme events like this
fires and droughts and
that you know the kind of conditions
that lead to fires
there may be little humans can do but
adapt
by building away from forested areas and
eliminating sources of ignition like
power lines
our warming world has left us few other
options
jackson prosco global news washington
travel from the united states to canada
is looking a little more normal
border restrictions lifted today for
fully vaccinated americans who want to
visit
the move couldn't come soon enough for
loved ones separated for more than a
year
and businesses that rely on tourist
dollars but as abigail beamon reports
the u.s is grappling with rising case
counts
and that's raising concerns about the
risk of spread
at the world's longest land border long
lines beat the sunrise
we reached here at
5 55 in the morning for many reasons
many fully vaccinated americans were
eager to get into canada on the first
day possible
worth the wait we're going to our
cottage just moving for school
been almost two years so grandparents
great grandparents for the kids
they came by car even by bike after one
year i'm going to visit my family
and of course by plane i'm excited i'm
beyond
emotional montrealer nicole brackett is
seeing her parents for the first time in
two years
it's been too long it's been way too
long where's the coldest beer
and while the opening may be long
overdue for many
there are concerns as cases in the
united states skyrocket
now topping a hundred thousand a day
here's a look at the united states
versus india
canada just extended its ban on direct
flights from india to september 21st
that was due to the delta variant which
originated there but indian cases have
since
dropped off dramatically to me we're not
ready for this widespread travel
this public health professor says rapid
testing needs to be more accessible
first
and she's worried about children with an
increase in american pediatric covet
cases
we also have to make sure that this
variant isn't just particularly hard on
children
and to me that that question hasn't been
fully answered yet while dr isaac bogash
stresses vaccines are working
and while it's true a vaccinated person
can still transmit the virus
it's less likely if you're going to take
a first step
in opening the border this would be an
appropriate first step to do so this is
about as safe as it gets
and as cautious as it gets the
government says it will be watching test
positivity rates closely after this
latest border reopening stressing
americans still need to take
one test before they arrive and another
once they get here
september 7th is the date people from
other countries are supposed to be
allowed in
we'll see if the delta variant changes
anything
abigail bieben global news ottawa
dozens of anti-vaccine protesters
clashed with police in london when they
attempted to storm what they seem to
think
was a major bbc news building
a wall of officers guarded the doors
while demonstrators tried pushing their
way
into the building demonstrators appear
to be targeting the bbc which they say
promotes covet 19 vaccines
but the bbc's news operation largely
left the building nearly a decade ago
more than 25 000 new cases were reported
in the uk
today in order to get into restaurants
in france people must now show a qr
code proving they have either been
vaccinated or received a recent
negative test result the virus pass will
also be needed to travel long distance
by train or bus
or to visit a hospital or nursing home
children under 12
are exempt for the past four weekends
protests have taken place in france
against
the virus pass another province is
joining ottawa's 10
a day child care plan adding to the
speculation of a federal election
coming up the potential liability for
the liberals if they call a vote
manitoba has signed on to the federal
government's 10 a day
daycare plan the agreement will cut
child care costs
in half for families with children up to
six years old by the end of 2022.
by 2023 regulated child care spaces in
manitoba
will cost an average of 10 dollars a day
the agreement will also create
23 thousand full-time regulated spaces
by 2026.
now manitoba is the seventh province to
sign on to the federal daycare plan
the trudeau government first announced
the initiative last month
fueling speculation of an early election
call
let's bring in our mercedes stevenson
who has been keeping us up to speed on a
possible writ drop this week
first of all let's talk timing the
liberals say they need to hold an
election to govern but what's the
political calculation here
robin the calculation is all about
whether the liberals
can get a majority government it's the
risk of going to the pools
in what some will see as a pandemic
power grab
but one that holds the intoxicating
possibility for the liberals
of a wind that would guarantee them four
more years
and insulate them against any possible
post-pandemic political backlash
the fourth wave has the opposition
calling the liberals irresponsible
for thinking about triggering a
non-essential election that would see
across canada campaign and tours but a
fourth wave
may not hurt the liberals politically
voters tend to favor incumbent
governments in times of crisis
and other countries and provinces have
held successful pandemic elections
but with covet numbers on the rise and
exponentially higher right now
than they were at this time last year
and continuing to climb
with the delta variant it means that the
clock is ticking on that rit dropping
mercedes can the liberals do this that's
a question a lot of folks are asking and
the answer is
yes but it is highly unusual for a
minority government
to voluntarily take itself to the polls
instead of losing to the opposition
in a non-confidence vote in the house
there is a fixed election law that has
created some confusion
it was introduced by prime minister
harper and largely designed to stop
majority governments
from abusing their power by calling snap
elections
but experts say the law does not
override the constitution
which would allow for the governor
general only to refuse trudeau's
requests on two grounds
either a very recent election election
say one that had taken place just a
matter of months ago
or if there was another party or
coalition ready to gather
govern neither of those options appear
to be on the table right now
at the end of the day the the cost of
the
of an early dissolution is going to be a
political one and it's a political risk
that the prime minister has to run
this isn't a question of violating a law
so can the liberals call an election
absolutely
should they well that question will be
left up to voters
robin mercedes stevenson and ottawa
thanks mercedes
still ahead we talked to a climate
expert on what the un's grim warning
means
for our future
[Music]
welcome back we continue our coverage
into that report by the un's
intergovernmental panel on climate
change
the co-author of the report is shubham
zhang a climatologist with environment
canada
and he joins us now from vaughan ontario
dr zhang the key finding is the world is
warming at a pace that is unprecedented
at that and the evidence is obvious in
the droughts and wildfires we're
currently experiencing
in your report you say it's only getting
worse can you explain that and why this
should be a wake-up call
well when you look at changes in the
weather extremes it is happening
everywhere
not just something happening in canada
but everywhere a closer globe in every
region in the globe so we are seeing
increase
in cold temperatures in cold extremes in
every region around the world
so that is a really really big workout
for because it's not just
something that you can see somewhere but
it's everywhere but many countries
including canada
are dependent on fossil fuels what needs
to change
well we need to find a way such that we
can
reduce our dependence on fossil fuels we
need to use new technologies
and to to to reduce these dependencies
because
no matter what we just we need to find a
way to reduce the emissions
that's the only way otherwise with more
emissions with temperature we're just
getting rice and things we're getting
much worse and worse
is it possible to limit global warming
at this point or is it too late
uh it's not completely too late we are
close but it's not too late as long as
we have
as long as we do a deep and sustained
reduction we shall still be
there's still time to act what ways can
human beings change their behavior to
make this a better place
we need to think about how we have our
life how we live our life we need to
think about how we use our energies
perhaps even what we eat and what we do
so uh so it is important that we need to
think about what's what is the best for
our life and also what's best for our
future
generations are there specific examples
that you can show us about
how we can change our behavior
uh there are many different kind of
examples we
we can think about and all are centered
away is the uh with the
reduction of emissions for example there
is a uh
increasing demanding also increasing
development in renewable energies
both in terms of solar energies wind
energies and there are also other kind
of like a
hydro energy and so on if there was a
way for you to sum this
all up how much of a wake-up call is
this for
the world and for canada
oh this is a huge weather call you see
that
we are facing covet and uh and
in the past nobody probably would think
the corvette is really i mean the the
kind of magnitude
of damage that uh this kind of disease
can cause to us
but now with the climate change this is
something
perhaps several magnitudes bigger down
the road so this is a huge wake-up call
dr zhong thank you so much for your time
thank you up next boycotting beijing why
some countries aren't eager
for the next olympics
the 2022 winter olympics are less than
six months away and problems are
plaguing these games
there have been calls for a boycott
because of china's human rights record
and as crystal commansing reports
canada's tense relationship with china
seems to be deadlocked to be a part of
the olympic games i mean it's the
olympic games but i'm
fired up just talking about it the push
for hockey gold is
already underway even though it's not
yet clear if
nhl players will be going to the 2022
games
but no matter who's competing beijing as
a host city right now
is problematic for many they need the
real
olympians to be performing on that stage
beijing ivy lee says the games are an
international propaganda show by china
the world's participation she says
fuel for the regime hungry to legitimize
its actions against its own people
and others including canadians i think
it's very
very cruel and unfair
to our ethnics
beijing has already hinted at extra
restrictions on athletes and anyone in
the country for the games
possibly beyond strict pandemic controls
although specifics are not yet public
control is always a factor in china
and enforcement has stretched onto the
streets of hong kong
with new national security laws beijing
however
promises a simple safe and splendid
games the canadian olympic committee has
dismissed calls to
boycott the winter olympics saying
staying home
doesn't change anything canada-china
relations are nearly
non-existent with the continued
detention of michael spavor
and michael kovrick the two men will
have spent
four years in custody by the time the
game starts
and canadian mps voted to declare
china's treatment of uyghur muslims
a genocide this year amid extensive
reporting
of human rights abuses asked about the
issue last week the ioc
president thomas bach avoided the
question as his spokesperson said the
focus
should be on tokyo it's no surprise say
those who study the ioc this is a really
critical
issue and it's not going away and there
are
calls throughout the world there are
protests on an ongoing basis
about the situation and that the ioc
needs to listen
politics the pandemic it's all more
pressure on athletes
who just want to compete crystal
gomanson global news
london and that is global national for
this monday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is eucloulet bc we
would love to see your corner of the
country so please
keep sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Applause]
[Music]
you